[موسيقى]
النقاط الاساسيه هو ان العديد من الدول
الاوروبيه تقول باندا لاين لم تستطع
مقاومه الضغط الكبير من قبل رئيس ورئيسه
الحكومه الايطاليه التي هي تعاني من ضغط
جديد صحيح على شواطئها وبالتالي طلبت
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يتخذ موقفا والا فان
ايطاليا لن تتمكن لن تتمكن ولن تسمح في
النهايه بوصول المهاجرين الخلافات تتعاون
مجالات متعدده مثلا قضيه اليه مراقبه هذه
الاتفاقيه كيف يمكن الربط ما بين التنميه
الاقتصاديه الموعوده لتونس وقضيه ثانيه هي
اصلا ليست تونس لديها مسؤوليه وهي قضيه
الهجره الغير النظاميه والنقطه الثالثه هي
قضيه كما اشار اليها العديد من النواب
المنتمين الى تيار واحد داخل البرلمان
الاوروبي وهي ان هذا الاتفاق هل هو في
النهايه
على بياض للرئيس قيس سعيد المشكل في هذه
النقاط الموجوده في هذا الاتفاق انها غير
واضحه
الينا فقط مختصون كمختصين في هذا المجال
وانما لي العديد من المكونات المجتمع
المدنيه التي تعمل على قضايا الهجره
واللجوء منذ سنوات جاءت في الحقيقه جاءت
معممه في اكثرها ولكن ما هو ظاهر في هذا
الاتفاق هو عمليه الترحيب القصري والجماعي
للمهجين التونسيين اول مهاجرين من جنسيات
افريقيا جنوب الصحراء كل موضوع انسان يؤخذ
على بعد سياسي تصبح هناك مشاكل وهذه
المواضيع التي تطرح مثل قضايا الهجره
واللجوء هي مواضيع اجتماعيه انسانيه
بالاساس فاتخاذ بعد سياسي في ابتزاز تونس
بتمويلها ب 900 مليون اورو في المقابل
بترحيل التونسيين من ايطاليا او من الفضاء
الاوروبي والجديد في هذه الاتفاقيه هو
ترحيل التونسيين من فضاء شينج يعني من
الاتحاد الاوروبي كاملا اولمبي ان هذه
الاتفاقيه فيها الغام كثيره هناك يعني
كلام في المطلق لا يوجد تفسير واضح للنقاط
وخاصه النقطه التي تتعلق بمشكله الهجره
التي يعني شكلت تجاذب خاصه في الراي العام
السياسي الايطالي ولونا ان اليوم من
المخجل ان تقوم اوروبا
بامضاء مذكره من هذا القبيل مع
نظام في تونس نظام يعني
يستعمل في الكتابه عبارات عنصريه يستعمل
في خطابه كذلك عبارات يعني
ينددون بها الاوروبيين
الخطاب السياسي شرعا لكل ما يحدث فيه
اشاره نحن في تونس وتحدث تقنيا لدينا
القوانين التي تحمي حقوق الانسان وتحمي
حقوق الافراد بصفه عامه ولكن عندما يكون
الخطاب السياسي فيه نوع من النعرات
العنصريه او التمييزيه يصبح الشارع
التونسيه الذي يتبنى هذا الخطاب السياسي
عنيف نوعا ما نحو فئه معينه والمشكل ان
السلطه السياسيه
جعلت كل مواطني صفاقس يواجهون هذه الازمه
لوحدي دون تدخل ماذا فعلت السلطه السياسيه
في حمايه اللاجئ في حمايه المهاجرين
بتوفير التغطيه الصحيه في توفير العديد من
الخدمات يجب ان ننسى بان هذه الاتفاقيه
وضعها القانوني اتفاقيه دوليه وبالتالي
الدول الاخرى الاعضاء الاتحاد الاوروبي
لمطالبه قبل كل شيء بالمصاد عليها قبل ان
يتم ان تصبح ساريه المفعول الى هناك بدا
وزارات الداخليه وهم يترقبون فعلا اذا
استطاعت اذا استطاع الاتحاد الاوروبي
التمريض هذه الاتفاقيه ان يتم استنساخ هذه
الاتفاقيه ويقولون بان في النهايه ما تم
التوقيع بين الاتحاد الاوروبي بكل دوله
وتركيا كان في النهايه يعني عملا من على
الحد او التقليل من عدد المهاجرين من
تركيا الى اوروبا فهناك المفارقه صحيح
هناك يعني احتياجات احتياجات كبيره من قبل
العديد من النواب داخل البرلمان الاوروبي
هناك كذلك يعني تفاصيل في هذه الاتفاقيه
وهو ما هي التعاون الامني ما معنى التعامل
الامني ان اليوم يحق لوكالات استخبارات
الحدوديه مثل ان يقوم بتنسيق او يقوم
بعمليات داخل التراب هذه هي الرساله التي
تريد ان تبعثها اوروبا الى دول شمال
افريقيا ان الجو عليها ان تنسق معاد الدول
وان تجعل يعني هذه الحدود هي حدودها
الاولى امام المهاجرين كل الازمات التي
يعيشها العالم وخاصه في الشراقه الاوسط
وبعض البلدان ايضا والحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه المتواصله حدود الان كل هذه
الازمات التي يعيشها العالم الاقتصاديه
والانسانيه لن تزيد كل هذه الاتفاقيات الا
سوءا للوضع الانساني وخاصه في قضايا
الهجره خاصه مع مشاكل التغيرات الم ناخيه
الوحيد هم المهاجرين حقوق المهاجرين
بالنسبه للحكومات حكومات شمال افريقيا هي
تعتبر منتصره لانها استطاعت ان تصبح محاور
مهم جدا ومقبول من قبل الدول الغربيه
واوروبا كذلك يمكن ان تقول في النهايه
بانها استطاعت ان تجد اتفاقا من اجل حد من
الهجره